dodgers coming to the plate here first
in the first
inning they're the road team now mookie
bentz will try to get it going for the
dodgers here tonight he jumps on the
first pitch grounds to third that's a
fair ball
tough play and got him and that's all
freddie freeman
but they're going to challenge that the
speed of bets look for the dodgers they
need all they can get going early to
take the lead
and he's safe all right lead off man is
on infield hit by betts
and now seeger jumps on the first pitch
drives it into left center and that ball
is cut off but all the way around
in two pitches the dodgers strike first
bets from first one to nothing
on an rbi double by corey seeger this is
a tough matchup against
will smith good sinking fastball hitter
here's one well hit into center that
ball is down
base hit for smith it's two to nothing
and
smoke is in the second with a double
two-nothing dodgers on top
as smith delivers his first lcs rbi
well how big is this inning gonna be
right now that's up to kyle wright
and jack peterson here's a shot into
left center field back
at the wall it's gone what a start for
the dodgers jack peterson goes deep
and it's a five-run first inning thanks
now to a three-run
shot by peterson all of this starting on
that close play at first
here is a shot to center by rios back at
the wall
that is gone wow
six to nothing dodgers on top
and have they been waiting for this type
of outburst
seeger bangs one to center field that's
going to drop in for a base hit
taylor comes in to score and bett slides
in safely
at third the dodgers lead it seven to
nothing and we're not finished with the
first
runners on at first and third and now a
run will score as that gets away from
darneau
and going all the way to third as
darneau didn't
find the ball i think darneau is
claiming that that
hit turner ball that got behind him
let's see
yeah he put his leg he literally kicked
it
hit batsman the bases are loaded and the
batter is max
muncie with two out here in the first
inning
here's a fly ball into right center
field back
at the wall it is gone
grand slam and the first innick
is historic
11 runs on the board for the dodgers
as they are just dropping bombs here in
the first
inning
here's a high fly ball into left center
field ballinger back on the move he
is there to end the inning
i think the dodgers are having fun
tonight and the dodgers bat
in the second after an 11 run first
call here's one into right back at the
wall it
is gone off the bat of bellinger home
run number
four on the night for the dodgers
and ballinger is finding that stroke
corey seeger who's two for two three run
homer and an rbi double and a run scored
in his last two played appearances last
night
and he just touches one off
wow in a dodger lineup that is suddenly
absolutely red hot he is the hottest one
2-2 pitch and another run up the middle
another hit for bellinger
and to score is muncie
and it's 15 to nothing here in the third
inning
the number nine hitter to the rookie two
for 10
as a big leaguer overall that
is hit in the air down the left field
line
it is gone
for a home run
goes deep first big league home run
here is a one two from urias a strikeout
of swanson
strikeout number four 1-0 pitch
is popped into left
long run for camargo
what a play by camargo
the dodgers will have to crank it up
again tomorrow night this one is a
play by muncie good feed and cleric
is there and game three now officially
belongs to the dodgers
15-3